bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi
nous reviendrons sur la journée
nationale de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé le président
de la république dans un discours a
annoncé aujourd'hui que dès l'an
prochain cette question historique sera
inscrite dans les manuels scolaires du
primaire
le bilan s'alourdit de jour en jour en
birmanie pendant ce temps la junte
elle s'affiche dans les bureaux de vote
pour son référendum
l'aide humanitaire internationale arrive
au compte-gouttes nous retrouverons à la
frontière birmane notre envoyé spécial
dans un instant on l'appelle le fantôme
parce qu'on ne connaît ni son nom ni son
visage cela fait quinze ans que la
police seulement de recherche qui se
cache derrière une série de meurtres
inexpliqués seul indice une empreinte
adn
celle d'une femme c'est le grand format
de ce soir il ne fait pas bon exploiter
une station essence en france à
proximité de la frontière espagnole
jusqu'à 20 centimes d'euros moins cher
l'essence ibérique séduit vous le verrez
de plus en plus de conducteurs français
en fin de rencontre à la fin de ce
journal avec un chef étoilé qui aiment
les voyages
après avoir fait le tour du monde
olivier roellinger nous recevra dans ses
cuisines de cancale pour un samedi soir
épicé comme il les aime
on le retrouve tout à l'heure à la fin
de cette édition merci d'être avec nous
on commence ce journal par la
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé une cérémonie a eu lieu en
fin de matinée à paris au jardin du
luxembourg
le président de la république qui a tenu
un discours l'occasion pour nicolas
sarkozy vous le disais en titre
d'annoncer que ce thème serait désormais
au programme des enfants des écoles
primaires dès l'an prochain reportage
gilles leclair thierry kurt et et
jean-marie le quartier tout faire pour
ne rien oublier
pour cette seconde cérémonie commémorant
l'abolition de l'esclavagé qui date de
nicolas sarkozy a voulu ce matin
s'adresser à tous aux anciens comme aux
plus jeunes le devoir de mémoire doit
s'imposer
les dirigeants comme il manque rien
comme dumas nuit donc pourquoi c'est une
journée comme celle prise est important
ynwa l'itif il faut ainsi cette histoire
le président de la république l'annoncé
sera bien inscrite dans les manuels
scolaires du primaire dès la rentrée
prochaine une page que tous les français
doivent assumer des esclavages est une
blessure
c'est une blessure profonde qui pèsent
encore sur nos consciences et les
mémoires porte le poids de cette
histoire les je sais bien qu'il existe
encore aujourd'hui des inégalités qui
trouvent leur origine dans cet héritage
si douloureux l'année dernière nicolas
sarkozy présidait aux côtés de jacques
chirac cette première cérémonie sur
toutes ces questions des valeurs
universelles à ses yeux tous les
français doivent aujourd'hui être
rassemblé et à noter qu'en marge de
cette journée de commémoration le
conseil représentatif des associations
noires le cran a manifesté aujourd'hui à
paris rappelant que la discrimination en
france en matière d'accès au travail au
logement était toujours d'actualité dans
les têtes ce samedi l'inquiétude de la
famille et des amis d'un jeune étudiant
à grenoble celui ci âgé de 21 ans a tout
simplement disparu depuis le 1er mai la
police a décidé d'ouvrir une enquête
pour disparition inquiétante et ses
proches multiplient les recherches le
point sur cette affaire avec chantal
kimmerlin voici la dernière photo de
mathieu jali go elle a été prise le soir
même de sa disparition lors d'une soirée
entre amis dans la nuit du 30 avril
mathieu âgé de 21 ans a quitté son
groupe d'amis à 4 heures du matin sur
les bords de l'isère à grenoble
légèrement éméché il voulait rentrer
chez lui à pied et il avait fait des
projets pour le week end
mercredi après-midi à appuyer
tout avait l'air bien ils avaient prévu
ce week-end parce que nous n'était pas à
la maison donc il me disait qu'il allait
à venir avec des copains chez nous et il
a parlé avec son petit frère enfin il
avait l'air bien quoi il avait dit que
le lendemain le jeudi avait prévu de
faire un foot bon copain fidèle en
amitié est née très proche de son jeune
frère mathieu n'a jamais été du style à
ne pas donner de nouvelles pour
expliquer sa disparition les enquêteurs
évoquent un état dépressif
ce que réfute ses amis qui le
connaissent depuis près de dix ans non
c'est pas mathieu du tout ses pensées de
terre il va le voir du monde quand ça va
pas quand j'ai dit à tout le monde qu'il
a disparu tout on a dit nabila des pas
bien pour même personne avait donné fera
quoi les amis de mathieu ont créé un
site internet la police grenobloise a
ouvert une enquête pour disparition
inquiétante et met à disposition un
numéro le 04 76 60 42 fois quand il a
disparu mathieu portait un blouson gris
et bleu sur le pull rayé que l'on voit
sur sa dernière photo
cet accident ce matin sur l'autoroute
a64 entre tarbes et toulouse
c'est un minibus appartement à la
communauté religieuse implantée à
lourdes qui a effectué plusieurs
tonneaux
neuf jeunes femmes ont été blessées dont
quatre grièvement
les images de l'un des premiers
incendies de la saison dans le var le
feu s'est déclaré à la suite d'un
écobuage sur la commune de montaroup
près de 350 pompiers et deux canadairs
sont immobiles
sur le sinistre le démantèlement d'une
vaste escroquerie à la carte bancaire le
montant du préjudice est estimé à un
million d'euros
tous les suspects ont été écroués à
l'issue de leur garde à vue à bourges
dans le cher
les sept personnes interpellées pratiqué
entre autres ce que les enquêteurs
appellent le skimming
en quoi consiste cette méthode
explications pauline d'ordi le skimmer
était dissimulée dans ce distributeur
automatique de saint-florent-sur-cher
skimmer le petit nom d'un boîtier
électronique caché dans la fente de
l'appareil lorsque vous insérez votre
carte
il enregistre vos données bancaires et
permet de fabriquer de fausses cartes de
crédit la plupart du temps la victime
n'y voit que du feu
vous avez d'abord inclure crespin serré
ici si ce n'est sur la fente et parfois
on peut remarquer parce que les petites
flèches sont cachés parce que c'est un
nombre de points supplémentaires
les victimes des dizaines dans toute la
france ont découvert sur leur relevé de
compte des retraits à l'étranger en
quelques mois grâce à cette méthode
un réseau de faussaires originaires
d'europe de l'est a accumulé plus d'un
million d'euros groupe agissait de
manière structurée organisée en
différents points du territoire national
et kourtney pouvoir couvrir l'ensemble
du territoire
très mobile et très organisés puisqu'il
dispose de support de nos produits de
base arrière ailier de congé khalid
difficile le bois investiguer certains
membres présumés ont été arrêtés en
plein jour alors qu'ils tentaient de
piéger un distributeur
les gendarmes ont retrouvé sur des skis
moeurs des mini caméras et des faux
claviers indétectable il servait à
enregistrer le code secret des victimes
en france les fraudes à la carte
bancaire coûte chaque année 250 millions
d'euros actuels et à l'étranger
maintenant et on commence par
l'évolution de la situation en birmanie
situation plus qu'étrange aujourd'hui
puisque la junte militaire au pouvoir
avait vous le savez maintenu son
référendum alors que le pays est dévasté
je vous rappelle que l'on parle toujours
de près de cent mille victimes
une situation et un régime qui a
condamné aujourd'hui clairement nicolas
sarkozy on écoute le chef de l'état je
pense à ce moment à la tragédie que
vivent le peuple de birmanie
où la communauté internationale veut
venir en aide de ce peuple et où un
régime éminemment condamnable en est à
empêcher le débarquement de vivre pour
permettre de soulager la misère
provoquée par un cyclone qu'à créer des
milliers de morts et des dizaines de
milliers de sans abri alors voyons ce
soir si l'aide humanitaire arrive sur
place en selle encore que la junte
pratiquer des restrictions les
journalistes de leur côté ne peuvent
entrer sur le territoire on entre donc à
la frontière avec la thaïlande notre
envoyé spécial loïc de la mornais
bonsoir loïc vous avez vu aujourd'hui
passés les premiers convois humanitaires
à destination de la birmanie
oui laurent je me trouve à 300 mètres de
la birmanie il suffit d'emprunter ce
pont que vous voyez derrière moi pour
arriver dans la petite ville de myawaddy
qui est la première ville qu'on
rencontre en birmanie alors
effectivement aujourd'hui les tout
premiers convois terrestres humanitaires
ont emprunté ce pont il s'agissait de
deux camions des nations unies chargé
seulement seulement de dix mille tentes
et dix mille tentes comparé au million
de réfugiés qui attendent des secours
c'est bien peu c'est une goutte d'eau
mais c'est un as et un début cela dit ça
n'a pas été sans mal car il a fallu que
ces deux camions empruntent le pont et
ils ont dû s'arrêter au milieu car les
conducteurs thaïlandais ont dû descendre
pour être relevés pour avoir un relais
par des conducteurs birman qui étaient
les seuls autorisés à transporter ces
camions jusqu'aux zones sinistrées dont
vous voyez que ce n'est pas encore très
facile les portes sont loin d'être
grande ouverte
et aujourd'hui on aurait effectivement
préféré entendre beaucoup plus l'écho
des moteurs des camions humanitaires
plutôt que l'écho des haut parleurs delà
de la propagande birmane qu'on entendait
très bien ici appelant régulièrement à
voter pour ce référendum soit disant
démocratique et puis le fait que vous
avez croisé je crois également à mayotte
des soldats américains
oui alors c'est la toute dernière
information de ces derniers or dernières
heures nous avons vu arriver une
quarantaine de militaires américains en
uniforme nous les avons d'autant plus
qu'ils sont dans le même hôtel que nous
et ils sont officiellement en mission
d'observation et de prospection autour
de l'aéroport de mayotte
concrètement
cela veut dire qu'il prépare peut-être
l'aéroport de mayotte à recevoir
pourquoi pas une base américaine où des
gros porteurs américains
cela pourrait être en tout cas être le
début de cette opération souhaité par le
président américain george bush qui à le
donner son feu vert pour qu'une
opération humanitaire soit lancé sur la
birmanie
merci le hic pour toutes ces précisions
le grand format de ce soir avec l'une
des plus vastes enquêtes policières
jamais lancée en allemagne il s'agit
d'une série de meurtres inexpliqués
seule une trace adn fait figure d'un 10
une empreinte génétique qui est celle
d'une femme mais une femme qui reste
toujours introuvable reportage lionel
feierstein et thomas donzel
c'est une plaie qui ne se referme pas un
traumatisme pour tous les policiers
allemands il y a tout juste un an
mourrait sur ce parking une de leurs
collègues abattu froidement d'une balle
dans la tête
ce jour là l'officier que l'air était de
permanence c'était horrible
un meurtre c'est toujours épouvantable
mais la voir une collègue couverte de
sang une collecte qui portent exactement
le même uniforme que vous allongée sur
le sol baignant dans son sang
et c'est un supporter après clé sur
place personne n'a rien vu
il n'y a aucun témoin direct du meurtre
de michel keith better en fait c'est à
l'intérieur de la voiture
sur le tableau de bord et les portières
que les enquêteurs vont trouver de
précieux indices concernant la présence
lors du crime d'un mystérieux personnage
prenne forme
après cinq semaines de recherches
intensives ont nous avons passé tout le
véhicule au peigne fin
nous avons découvert de nombreuses
traces adn dont celle d'une personne de
sexe féminin impliqué dans une trentaine
d'affaires
une femme sans visage sans âge sans
identité la presse allemande vient de là
surnommé le fantôme d'heilbronn depuis
15 ans elle sévit dans tout le sud du
pays un parcours criminel unique
commencé en 1993 dans la petite ville
tranquille dida robert stein
sa première victime est une retraitée de
62 ans
liselotte schlienger elle vivait seul
avec son chien au premier étage de cette
maison
sa voisine s'en souvient encore très
bien par mois du salon était tout faire
je pense qu'on lui a volé de l'argent
mon mari a vu son corps allongés sur le
sol elle avec un tir de faire tout
autour du cou greenpeace est comme ça qu
ils l'ont tué
art huit ans plus tard la tueuse
réapparait tout d'un coup du côté de
fribourg sa deuxième victime est un
brocanteur joseph van sant bar
dépouillés puis étranglé seuls éléments
laissés sur place
l'adn toujours le même celui de la femme
sans visage
entre 2001 et 2008 les policiers vont en
découvrir par tous souvent par hasard
sur des objets très différents une
seringue dans un parc pour enfants des
gâteaux dans une caravane fractures et
des canettes de bière et sur le bouchon
du réservoir d'essence d'une voiture
volée et même de l'adn sur une balle qui
a failli tuer un membre d'une communauté
gitane lors d'un règlement de comptes
il n'y a pas d'explication logique c'est
incompréhensible lorsque l'on regarde
toutes les traces adn qu'elle a laissé
derrière elle on ne peut pas dire que
c'est une grande professionnelle à
l'ombre du fantôme s'est également
déplacée en france
arbois dans le jura en septembre 2004 un
couple de commerçants vietnamiens est
agressé par plusieurs gangsters cagoulés
les auteurs sont rapidement arrêtés puis
au cours de l' enquête les gendarmes
français prélève un échantillon des dna
l'intérieur d'un jouet un pistolet en
plastique qui selon la mère appartient à
ce fils ma connaissance les épreuves ne
sont jamais rendues en allemagne sont
arrivés en france dans un camp de
réfugiés à paris puis à dijon etc sont
ensuite installés à royat nombreuses
années en 2006 la sphère de la tueuse
son visage devient encore plus complexe
cette année là les policiers retrouvent
sur une pierre jetée dans une vitre une
nouvelle trace adn de la femme
coup de chance un témoin assisté à
l'acte de vandalisme
problème la personne qui l'a vu est en
fait un homme cet homme
les enquêteurs s'interrogent et si la
tueuse était un transsexuel
lorsqu'on regarde les résultats des
analyses scientifiques les chercheurs
allemands et autrichiens choix on est
sûr à 100% qu'il sèche d'une femme passe
mais nous n'excluons pas d'après notre
enquête qu'elle puisse avoir une
apparence et dj set au masculin
pour l'instant la femme sans visage est
soupçonné d'avoir participé à six
meurtres et plus d'une vingtaine de vols
et cambriolages
malgré des dizaines de milliers d'heures
dans quai de recherche en france en
autriche et en allemagne
le fantôme d'heilbronn reste toujours
introuvable la justice allemande excédé
offre désormais cent mille euros à
quiconque permettra de l'identifier
vous le savez l'italie de nouveau passé
à droite avec à sa tête une nouvelle
fois silvio berlusconi mais c'est une
autre victoire symbolique qui a retenu
l'attention ces derniers jours la base
celle de gianni alemanno il a conquis la
mairie de rome qui était depuis 15 ans à
gauche un conservateur controversé au
discours sécuritaire affirmé et qui a
été un temps membre d'un parti
néofasciste notre équipe a pu le suivre
à rome voici le reportage de karine
comazzi et green guillaumin gianni
alemanno est un homme pressé
il faut dire que son parti la droite
dure et nationalistes attendait cette
victoire à la mairie de rome depuis la
fin de la guerre aujourd'hui encore le
nouveau maire s'étonne de son tour de
force
c'est étrange en fait je ne réalise que
maintenant que je suis le maire car
quand les problèmes commencent et que
tout le monde vous tombe dessus en même
temps alors
vous vous rendez compte que vous êtes le
maire de rome le maire d'une ville de 3
millions d'habitants
autant dire qu'il ne doit pas s'endormir
sur ses lauriers
allons-y à pied les romains réputés de
gauche l'ont largement élu près de 54%
des voix pour lui pas de paradoxe ils
ont avant tout choisi un homme
il ya beaucoup de sympathie et est tout
aussi les liens de la porte des gens de
gauche
ce jour-là exercice protocolaire
obligatoires
l'hommage à aldo moro et aux victimes du
terrorisme
mais ces engagements de mer sont
ailleurs gêné alemanno a promis selon
ses termes de nettoyer rome sa priorité
rétablir la sécurité
car à rome il ya trop de désordre trop
de chaos
je veux rendre cette ville plus sûre
pour tous ou là et du point de vue de la
beauté de la propreté moi j'ai un modèle
ses adversaires guette tout dérapage néo
fasciste mais celui qu'on surnomme lupa
manon le loup alemanno est un animal
politique prudent notamment rome est une
ville très démocratique qui n'auraient
jamais élu un maire fasciste une super
fasciste et donc tout le monde peut être
rassuré dans la presse du jour il se
découvre en empereur fossoyeur de la
gauche il ne boude pas son plaisir et
nous fait partager
regardez ça j'ai l'impression d'être au
centre du monde
j'ai un grand respect pour les racines
de ces nids visitation et je voudrais
que la rom d'aujourd'hui 10 soit digne
de celle du 1 allée mano en preuve
alemanno tribun de cette plèbe romaine
qui veut parler des problèmes de sa
ville un alemanno respect des personnes
qui sont là en bas et qu'ils veulent et
été et chaque année des romains vigilant
qui jugeront l'homme sur ses actes
la situation est toujours confuse ce
soir au liban après trois jours
d'affrontements et le coup de force du
hezbollah qui a pris position dans
l'ensemble du quartier ouest de beyrouth
l'armée libanaise ce n'était toujours
pas intervenue militairement en raison
notamment de sa composition multi
confessionnel c'est aujourd'hui
prononcer politiquement en quelque sorte
les explications de cette crise avec
jean-marc il use ce matin les moments
d'accalmie d'un beyrouth ouest sans
miliciens cet après-midi les instants de
folie qui ont suivi la mort de deux
civils tombés sous les balles des
tireurs embusquées alors qu'il suivait
l'enterrement d'un proche tué la veille
au cours d'affrontements avec le
hezbollah
la violence aussi dans le nord du liban
et une dizaine de morts dans l'attaqué
du siège d'une organisation pro syrienne
et puis l'appel lancé à une armée
libanaise bien passive par le premier
ministre libanais fouad siniora pour lui
demander de mettre fin au coup d'état
rampant du hezbollah et de débarrasser
les rues des miliciens pro syrien un
ordre bien impossible à exécuter par une
armée libanaise sous peine de voir ses
différentes composantes confessionnelles
entrer en conflit interne
et puis surprise sans tambour ni
trompette ce communiqué sur internet qui
désamorce le conflit l'armée ordonne le
retrait des mesures à l'origine du coup
de force du hezbollah ce que le
gouvernement signora se refusait à peine
voilà seulement 48 heures l'important
était de mettre un terme au coup d'état
rampant la tente au liban depuis
d'ailleurs deux ans et qui a trouvé son
point culminant dans cette invasion des
rues de beyrouth
en fait il se retire des rues de
beyrouth s'est déjà pour le gouvernement
à une victoire importante de la crise
libanaise poursuit et à cette crise
voilà donc le poids de la crise
transférer sur les épaules d'un homme
qui ne s'est pas montré aujourd'hui
michel slimane patron de l'armée
celui là même dont le football à bloc
depuis sept mois l'élection au poste de
président
décidément entre partisans et
adversaires du puissant voisin syrien
le bras de fer libanais continue nous
parions le week-end dernier de ce volcan
entre en éruption sud du chili est bien
une semaine après le redouble d'activité
continue de cracher des cendres ce qui a
obligé les autorités à évacuer en
totalité les habitants de régions au
delà des hommes c'est la situation
écologique qui inquiète les autorités
franck jojo
dans les airs le panache de cendres du
chaiten se confond désormais avec les
nuages à 12 kilomètres d'altitude au sol
c'est un paysage de désolation
tous les habitants ont été évacués dans
un rayon de 30 kilomètres derrière eux
des animaux laissés à l'abandon
affamés les autorités tentent de les
soigner et de les nourrir tant bien que
mal
l'eau et les pâturages sont désormais
impropre à la consommation dans une
région où le bétail est une des
premières sources de revenus un peu plus
loin les militaires des blés les toits
des maisons
les paysages sont comme enneigé mais
cette neige là est beaucoup plus
insidieux la neige sapho soleil mais ce
truc c'est très lourd et ça forme une
espèce de simone les scientifiques
redoutent une catastrophe écologique de
grande ampleur les cendres atteignent
désormais buenos aires à 1000 kilomètres
de là l'éruption pourrait durer de
longues semaines et il ya quelques
semaines nous vous parlions de ce jeune
français de 26 ans qui a disparu en inde
alors qu'il a effectué un long voyage à
vélo est bien la mère du jeune homme est
arrivé il ya quelques jours sur place à
bombay à la rencontre les policiers en
charge de la faire
arnauld miguet était avec elle depuis
une semaine madame talus et son fils
vincent arpente russe et parcs de bombay
avec leurs moyens eux ils cherchent à
retrouver jean baptiste le fils le frère
disparu en inde
il y a cinq mois des gens affichent
récompense de 3500 euros pour tout
témoignage
ils veulent savoir désespérément
si on retrouve pas des voûtes son vélo
d'ebooks en matériel ses papiers
déchirés ou des choses comme ça quelque
part c'est bon signe ça veut dire que
peut-être il a encore tout ça avec lui
jean baptiste 26 ans ce garçon sérieux
avide de lectures s'était embarqué l'été
dernier pour un périple d'un an au tour
du monde à vélo en solitaire il
communiquait avec sa mère par internet
régulièrement tous les huit jours
jusqu'à son atterrissage à bombay la
capitale économique de l'inde
ce que s'est-il passé ensuite des
maigres éléments de l'enquète révèle de
retrait de 20 et 200 euros à ce
distributeur automatique près de
l'aéroport
la dernière trace laissée par jean
baptiste talons dernier endroit où jean
baptiste a retiré de l'argent à six
heures du soir le 5 décembre et il ya
toujours un garde devant halla ici pour
moi j'ai beaucoup à comprendre pourquoi
aucun gars de ne dit que la vue jean
baptiste madame tall automne est à venir
sur place depuis la disparition de son
fils elle ne vit plus dit elle
la police indienne lui a promis qu'elles
continueraient d'explorer toutes les
pistes
dans cette mégapole de 16 millions
d'habitants six personnes disparaissent
tous les jours selon les chiffres de la
police
20 % seulement sont retrouvés la famille
tall eux espèrent toujours que leur fils
fera partie de cette dernière
statistique dans l'actualité en france
le blocage par des pêcheurs du port des
sables d'olonne en vendée
la raison de leur colère le prix élevé
le gazole est passé de 40 à 60 8
centimes d'euros en un an
il demande une nouvelle fois au
gouvernement un soutien financier
le blocage devrait se poursuivre jusqu'à
mardi le prix du gazole justement et de
l'essence qui est également une question
importante pour le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et certains n'hésitent pas dans
le sud ouest vous allez le voir à
traverser la frontière côtes espagnoles
là bas le prix du litre est inférieur de
20 centimes d'euro reportage véronique
guillaume et pascal pons vous faites
votre réserve
oui ces deux véhicules
donc j'ai fait la bringue cela est vrai
pour l'offre quand je gagne à peu près
20 centimes par litre on vient tous les
15 jours en espagne
les français peuvent gagner 10 à 15
euros par plein d'essence alors la
frontière est vite franchi
pour faire des affaires on parlait de
l'essence est intéressante pour
s'acheter une paire naissance aux trois
pour les parfums les alcool cigarettes
intéressante par rapport à celle - tout
en même temps tout en même temps oui le
passage à l'euro a favorisé les
comparaisons de prix et les migrations
et du côté français des pyrénées on ne
peut pas s'aligner les taxes en vigueur
sont différentes
toutes les stations petites ou grandes
accuse le coup pendant moins de
carburant puisque d'une année sur
l'autre on constate que nous avons une
régression de l'ordre de 10% dans de
litres vendus ici on ouvre même plus le
samedi
le chiffre d'affaires a été divisé par
deux en quinze ans entre la concurrence
des grandes surfaces et celle de
l'espagne les petites stations
françaises disparaissent du boulou
jusqu'au perthus où nous étions 10 quand
je suis arrivé avec trop peu près pour
un crunch dernière les villages
frontaliers perdent ainsi leur dernière
boutique et la flambée des prix du
pétrole semblant inéluctable rien ne
devrait arrêter la fuite des clients
notre rubrique mai 68 et retour ce soir
sur la vie quotidienne dans un lycée
censure mixité elle a eu un avant et un
après 68 nous avons choisi de retourner
au lycée condorcet à paris avec un
visiteur particulier le cinéaste romain
goupil souvenirs en images
aurélie bros thierry breton
il en a fait la scène de son premier
film quarante ans plus tard romain
goupil revisite ses souvenirs de lycéens
condorcet le décor de ces lycées
napoléonien n'a pas bougé d'un pouce
ce sont les moeurs qui ont bien changé
et ce que l'on sait ça c'était
absolument c'est un motif d'exclusion
immédiate visés quand j'étais môme et
d'être avec une fille ou plus de
sécurité sur un bon alors on n'est pas
du tout pareil au rayon surveillant
général hiver heureusement qu'elle soit
sortie
alors pour vous nous aussi d'ailleurs
dans son souvenir le lycée est une
prison grille souvenir amer cécile c4
c'était des lycées on devait se taire
l'autorité anja leur en mettre c'est
l'époque que les pions sont présents par
dizaines pour faire appliquer le
règlement est certain de rien alors à
discuter par l'aura de contester pas le
droit de dire le monde
si jamais qu'un pion ne voyait que le
monde ils le déchirent acte de menaces
des chromebook il sera exclu pour cause
d'activité politique à l'intérieur du
lycée le motif était d'avoir forcé les
autres élèves à ne pas venir au lycée
comment riche pu tenir un piquet de
grève sol alors qu'il y à deux portes
d'entrée
si la révolte gronde c'est aussi parce
que les lycées change de visage
obligé d'ouvrir leurs portes aux classes
moyennes le premier exemple de ses
premières classes d'âge du baby boom qui
va arriver en masse et c'est ça qui va
tout déstabilisé mieux leur
fonctionnement c'était vraiment une
petite élite qui étaient sélectionnés
tous les autres étaient envoyés dans les
c ôté
en quelques mois la vie quotidienne des
lycéens va être bouleversé la mixité va
se généraliser
les débats vont faire leur apparition
mai 1968 sonnera le glas de ce qu'on
appelait alors les lycées casernes ce
week-end à saint-malo se déroule la 19e
édition du festival du film et du livre
étonnant voyageur une invitation au
voyage à travers la littérature et
l'image et nous recevons ce soir l'un
des participants il est l'un des plus
grands chefs français breton et voyageur
puisqu'il revient d'un tour du monde
un livre lui est consacrée signé vincent
et christian lejalé bonsoir olivier
roellinger
je suis très heureux de vous avoir avec
nous dans vos cuisines ce samedi soir
avant de parler voyage plus est à table
mais alors c'est une question que les
clients se posent toujours un chef trois
étoiles doit-il toujours être dans sa
cuisine bref at il le droit d'être
absent je pense que ça dépend de la
nature de chacun moi il est vrai que il
m'arrive parfois de m'absenter alors que
la maison est ouverte parce que je mange
avait toute ma brigade qu'ils tiennent
parfaitement la maison mais je suis mal
à l'aise lorsque je ne suis pas là donc
je profite pas du tout de ma soirée à
l'extérieur et en dehors de ma maison
alors quel bon voilà je crois que c'est
ce qui vous a poussé à faire ce voyage
autour du monde et bien en réalité c'est
partir sur les traces des grandes
familles malouines qui ont créé la
compagnie des mers du sud il deviendra
la compagnie des indes et retrouver un
peu ces routes à travers le monde
en réalité c'est un hymne au métissage
des cuisines des mers du monde c'est un
peu pour écrire l'histoire du pays de
saint malo
vous étiez en quête de saveurs nouvelles
des pistes nouvelles parce que votre
cuisine est très épicée enfin en tout
cas oui mais enfin deux oui mais dans le
sens du parfum c'est vrai que depuis 25
ans
avec ma femme nous parcourons un peu le
monde entier en quête du mande repartir
sur la route des indes mais la route des
indes occidentales et orientales
mais dans l'esprit de la fin du 7e au
début du 18e pour pour présenter saint
malo comme étant un trait d'union un
marchepied de l' aventure et c'est pas
du tout dans l'esprit d'une cuisine
exotique s'est marié l'ici et l'ailleurs
avec un bigorneau ma crevette mon mac
row poetry mon petit crabe mais pas avec
une carte d'un môme le girofle le talent
au mas une ambre est mais des plus de
120 t pis il est vrai aujourd'hui menace
qu'on utilise un petit peu comme comme
une ponctuation littérature alors on
voit beaucoup de noms de s'activer
autour d'eux ou faites nous un petit peu
rêver qu est ce qu il ya à la carte ce
soir chez vous il ya évidemment il y
avait beaucoup de choses mais en ce
moment l'araignée de mer devient
parfaite donc on fait une association
avec une sauce coraline et puis un
avocat avait un curry vert un peu un peu
vietnamien et puis il ya un bouillon aux
saveurs tonkinoise mais qui sont très
très sèche en cornet petit ormeaux et
puis il ya le fameux turbo qui étaient
aux graines de pavot avec cette poudre
de talent au mas magnolia c'est que j'ai
trouvé l'hiver dernier à la frontière
chinoise
un dernier mot n'a pris aujourd'hui la
mort de l'un des plus grands chefs
français paulo berlin il était le
fondateur de l'auberge de lui mais le
prestigieux restaurant alsacien avec
trois étoiles au michelin
une réaction libéraux linge et bien
évidemment toute la cuisine française
est dans la peine profonde parce que
pour tous les cuisiniers
en france monsieur paul comme on
l'appelait monsieur paul haeberlin c'est
un petit peu comme notre grand oncle à
tous et il va beaucoup nous manquer et
évidemment on pense tous à cette
merveilleuse famille et berlin merci
beaucoup à vous et passer une belle
soirée dans votre cuisine le sport avec
du football et il y aura beaucoup de
stress ce soir dans les tribunes des
stades de ligue 1 en france la raison de
tout cela des matches à enjeu à
l'occasion de l'avant dernière journée
de championnat et il ya des espoirs de
titre de ligue des champions et des
craintes de descendre en ligue 2 bref
beaucoup de suspense voyons tout cela
avec nathanaël de rincquesen depuis près
de sept ans il soutient lyon au sommet
du football français
mercredi dernier en coupe de france
junhino encore sorti son équipe d'un
mauvais pas ce soir les supporteurs
lyonnais comptent sur lui pour battre
nancy et remporter le duel à distance
qui oppose le sextuple champion de
france aux girondins de bordeaux 2
points d'avancé à deux journées de la
fin bordeaux n'a pas dit son dernier mot
le titre n'est pas encore joué
observateur attentif l'om 4e du
classement espère bien bénéficier d'un
succès lyonnais sur l'ancien ce soir les
marseillais doivent impérativement
battre le mans pour récupérer la 3e
place synonyme d'accès à la lucrative
ligue des champions
bien malgré eux les joueurs du psg sont
concernés par ces plutôt européenne tout
à l'heure saint-etienne devra gagner au
parc des princes pour espérer se
rapprocher des places d'honneur
l'empoignade s'annoncent tendues entre
ceux qui ont tout à gagner et ce qu'ils
peuvent tout perdre on est en danger
mais mais n'empêche on est très motivé
le sheed est très conscient les efforts
que nous avons à faire les supporteurs
lensois aussi vont suivre cette avant
dernière journée du championnat
la peur au ventre comme toulouse et
paris lance à 39 points comme toulouse
et paris lens affronte un adversaire en
course pour une place en coupe d'europe
pour ces trois clubs la défaite est
interdite sous peine d'une probable
relégation ligue 2 seul le psg joue à
domicile un avantage indéniable qui a
souvent réussi aux joueurs parisiens
lors des matchs anges et on suivra les
résultats les analyses et les
commentaires de tout cela demain dès 12h
d'enfance de foot avec denis balbir de
la musique maintenant ils rêvent de la
renommée de tokio hotel et ils n'en sont
pas loin véritable star en asie le
groupe japonais l'arc en ciel en
français dans le texte débarque à paris
pour leur premier passage dans une
capitale européenne
ils ont rempli le zénith hier soir un
concert qui était retransmis en direct
au japon il ya six semaines jeannette et
sébastien laffargue sur place c'est
content de reprendre eux est praticienne
ne vous fiez pas à leur frêle silhouette
ce sont des géants du rock
elle
guitares saturées parole à l'eau de rose
13 millions d'albums vendus et des
centaines de japonaise qui traverse la
planète pour ne pas rater un seul
concert ce groupe est toute ma vie le
public une faune bigarrée d'adolescents
élevé aux jeux vidéo et aux mangas on
espérer les voir depuis tellement
longtemps comme un rêve
les fans récite parker des paroles
qu'elle ne comprenne pas l'oeil amusé
des japonaises
au fond premier concert en europe l'arc
en ciel a choisi paris mais ce n'est pas
un hasard alors l'arc en ciel dans ce
que visait en fait c'est plutôt d'aller
qu'un chien et loup et le disait la
japonaise
mais ça c'était comme en français et en
fait si l'on en a très très très fort
vis à vis de la culture française et
l'arc-en-ciel quatre gars faut au look
très étudié
ils ont 40 ans d visage d'adolescent et
la candeur qui va avec
c'était
je t'embrasse est mais encore
bon ce sera tout pour le discours en
tout cas l'arc en ciel est un exemple
criant de l'engouement des adolescents
pour la nouvelle culture japonaise
avant de refermer cette édition je vous
rappelle l'une des principales
informations ce samedi ce sont les
nouvelles informations en provenance du
liban le hezbollah et ses alliés ont
commencé à retirer leurs combattants des
quartiers ouest de beyrouth les
obéissent ainsi aux injonctions de
l'armée à un retrait qui intervient
également alors que les militaires ont
annoncé que le gouvernement gelé les
récentes décisions à l'encontre du
hezbollah décision qui avait embrasé le
lit morts ces derniers jours
voilà pour l'essentiel de l'actualité ce
samedi merci d'être fidèle à
l'information sur france 2 la météo donc
avec tania young puis dès 20h50 le plus
grand cabaret du monde avec l'ami
patrick sébastien demain dès midi france
de foot denis balbir on se retrouve à 13
heures pour l'information
l'invité de la page politique sera relis
filippetti je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr